so if you guys missed it chat this is
the news CS2 roster update hero is sad
to announce the sty yabi are temporarily
removed from the starting lineup and
then they said yo you either choose us
you either choose me or this other bloke
kadon guys what is going on with heroic
first we find out that their igl oper
captain and all around heart and soul of
the team Kaden gets benched then we find
out that it's because two of his
ostensibly closest teammates
wanted him out that's heroic side of the
story but is it
true first things first to all the
Counter-Strike fans out there we the
score Esports have a face it clan and
this weekend we are competing in
community Clash join me your friends and
our community as we grind for a 100,000
faet points starting today October 26th
to October 29th we're going to be
competing against ourselves and all the
other face of Clans in North America so
be sure to hop in and frag out it's free
to join links in the description all
right time
for whatever this heroic [__] is cuz I
am not going to cap with you home deadly
dog if what they are saying about Stan
and yabi is
true that wasn't very Cash Money of them
but let's rewind okay so for those who
don't know about 3 weeks ago Kaden the
face of heroic csgo and now two roster
was bed out of nowhere and it was in no
uncertain terms shocking like it just it
did not compute all heroic said was that
Kaden was stepping down that the
decision was mutual and that it stemmed
from them having differing Visions for
the future of the team which like is
always what you're going to say
obviously you don't air your dirty
laundry out on
Twitter yet anyway it didn't make sense
but we figured hey it's Esports stranger
things heroic as being being a big fat
silly goose bring the boy to liquid so
he can save na we take those and in all
fairness that's still hopefully what's
going to happen which is [__] sick
kadon comes out of all of this allegedly
with twists Naf Yi and skulls as
teammates which we love for him and the
dumpster fire that is nacf and then
earlier this week heroic came out with a
second roster announcement stating that
their star rifling Duo Stan and yabi
were also being benched which like huh
what so yeah apparently Stan and yabi
were the ones who wanted kadan out
apparently they went to heroic and said
if you bench him we'll extend our
contracts forc to pick between their igl
and their star rifling Duo heroic sided
with the duo now again to be clear this
is heroics side of the story in typical
Esports fashion Stan tweeted this
classically cryptic the truth will come
to light style idiot yesterday but as of
right now we don't know the whole story
so why is this so crazy well beyond the
obvious drama of it all if what heroic
is alleging is true this is a top 10
Esports anime betrayal since joining the
roster way back in 2020 Kaden has been
the heart and soul of Roo not only did
he help to mold both Stan and yabi into
the First Rate rifl they are today but
he aided the former as they both dealt
with some extremely stressful cheating
allegations yeah that's true I got
really sad what you said
that just what I knew that we can't hold
this back anymore these guys have been
through a lot together and we the
community always perceive them as being
very tight-knit
Arena [__] up to
[__]
[__] so if it's even a little bit
true that Stan and yabi in a word
backstabbed
Kaden that's pretty crazy what's worse
heroic are also alleging that the duo
backstabbed them there's a fair bit of
ugly nefarious history between heroic
and astralis and if the duo really did
leave one out to dry for the other
that's a bad look reactions ranged from
outrage to confusion to straight up
memes now if all of this is true I
completely understand why heroic opted
to air it to the public in this
particular case transparency was
definitely the way to go anyway that's
pretty much all we know as of right now
things will almost certainly continue to
unfold in the coming days so I'll be
sure to keep you
updated